[Music]
frank wilcheck is the hermann feshbach
professor of physics at the
massachusetts institute of technology
and the co-recipient with david gross
and david politzer of the 2004 nobel
prize in physics for insights into the
strong nuclear interactions among many
additional honors including the sakurai
prize and the dirac medal wilcheck has
recently been named a recipient of the
john templeton prize which honors
individuals whose exemplary achievements
harness the power of the sciences to
explore the deepest questions of the
universe and humankind's place
and purpose within it welcome frank and
congratulations on this prize from the
templeton foundation
i'd love to uh organize our conversation
around sort of three main themes
what we know
what we don't know and and why it all
matters and just jumping right in
you know mathematics is a powerful tool
for
gaining the insight that theoretical
physics has provided to the world and
many have marveled
at how
spectacularly
accurate and insightful mathematics can
be eugene vigner talking about the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics and physical sciences
like where do you come down
on this why is math so good at
describing the world well it didn't have
to be that way
and i think really it's a contingent
property of the way the laws actually
work
the laws
we've discovered the fundamental laws
have a property of locality that means
you can analyze really small things
accurately and then build up by
deduction so that's a kind of
mathematical approach
they have enormous amounts of symmetry
which also allows us to apply logical
deduction and
and
mathematical methods
it doesn't always work that way there
are domains of science that are not
fundamental physics
where the application of mathematics has
been much more limited
also you can imagine
computer worlds
intelligences inside
computers that
uh
that that would live in a world where
the laws are quite different and would
not be subject to uh easy mathematical
analysis because they just recommend or
just
represent the whims of the programmer
so
i think it's contingent on the way the
laws actually work
but
it as i said it didn't have to be that
way and it's a tremendous it's a
marvelous miraculous thing that it is
that way but in that in that simulated
world do you imagine that the computer
itself is running based on mathematical
ideas
and so are these individuals just being
fooled into thinking that the world
isn't mathematical yeah well that's
that's that's that's what i was actually
thinking about okay
but but how should i say for the
individuals involved these
notional individuals and artificial
intelligences involved in this
embodiment uh
the the the actual physical world that
we would think that they're you know at
a deeper level they're embodied in
might be very very difficult to access
so that's that's kind of part of the
thought experiment so so it could be
that we we live in a world where
thankfully the fundamental mathematical
substrate has been revealed to us could
you imagine the reverse is also true
that the fundamental substrate of our
world is not mathematical and we've just
been led to believe that it's based in
mathematical regularity i find that very
hard to imagine actually
because
the uh
the the the the
the second level that you're postulating
the deeper level that's
not mathematical i'm not sure what it
would be it would have to be some
uh
some very very long verbose program that
that somehow was designed to function as
if it's actually a very compact
logical program
yeah well
it's a it's a logical possibility but
boy ugly as hell
and uh
or simply beyond our imagination right
and and uh seems very far-fetched yeah
no i tend to agree with that of course
um but um
and and so um with with the power of
mathematics to describe the world does
that give you a sense
that math is out there
waiting to be discovered or that math is
part of our
approach to finding coherence and
therefore ultimately comes out of the
human mind
i think it's both
that is that
there are
mathematical truths
that are independent of
how you get to them so to be a
human mind or or some other kind of mind
would would arrive at uh
fermat's last theorem or goodell's
incompleteness theorem i think uh for
instance that
that that they have a kind of
mathematical truth
everyone would agree that there are five
platonic solids that
uh
however the focus of interest
might be quite different for different
kinds of intelligence
large parts of human mathematics
are crafted to be things that are
well adapted for the human mind to think
about
uh
so for instance theory or special
functions which is quite elaborate
is based and and different approximation
methods where you take the first few
terms of a series or so they they are uh
they are adapted to the fact that human
minds can only work out
a few
terms in the series
so uh
intelligence is with larger memories
with with faster computational
abilities uh would not be interested in
that as much
they would
be interested in different kinds of
questions or how if you if you want to
do celestial mechanics instead of
proving delicate theorems about
three-body problems you just compute
just compute
right
you don't you don't need these crutches
you just compute so so so the
uh there is a domain of mathematical
truth
however human creativity and taste goes
goes also into
into
creating the thing we call mathematics
relevant to that too is that fields of
mathematics uh go into and out of
fashion
historically you know there there was a
time when uh
projective geometry was extremely
popular and and
people
wrote textbooks about it and taught it
in school and so you know it's very
pretty it's a very pretty subject it has
connections to art and so but it's not
very fashionable anymore
uh and
you know it feeds into other things but
as as a self-contained thing is not
not really taught anymore so and so as
theoretical physicists though do you see
what we're doing
as making ever better models
mathematical models of reality or do you
see that these
mathematical endeavors will ultimately
uncover
the reality of how the universe works
well so far uh those things have
worked out remarkably harmoniously make
the model as we've
attempted to make
uh
models i guess the real question is
yes you can make models of the world and
as you accumulate more data
and more observations
you can always accommodate it by making
more and more complicated models
the real question is whether you can
continue with this program that's been
so successful so far
of
reducing the description to something
very compact
and
that's not guaranteed
but i don't at present it seems still
seems to be working pretty well
and i think definitely it's been the
main line of progress in modern physics
uh and i don't see any reason not to
keep going that way to hope that you
to to look for more and more reduced
descriptions
at some point that might become less
fruitful in fact i think we may be
reaching that point where
looking for
more and more reduced descriptions
uh may not be the most important thing
to be doing really
i mean if there were a deeper level of
structure
there's a possibility you think that
investigating it might not give the
insight that one would think it would
provide
no well it'll it'll provide insight but
there are many the world has many
problems
and and many opportunities
and it's it's not clear for instance
where
getting a an elegant theory of quantum
gravity ranks among the important human
problems and opportunities
that they're uh you know we would like
to understand
uh the origin of life we would in
physics we'd like to understand concrete
things like what is the dark matter
and
so they're different so
uh
getting more and getting a more and more
compact and reduced description
is a laudable goal but it's only one
among several and it's not clear to me
that it's the most important so so what
then does drive you you know for me it's
trying to find the deep
underlying description of the world
whatever that might be
independent of whether it may solve some
of the macroscopic problems that are of
course deeply important
but i gather the balance for you is a
little bit different
i think it's probably quite different i
i just want to do interesting things
and
i look for opportunities i look for weak
spots in our description of the world
or opportunities to to
improve
either our understanding of something or
our control of something
and i look for opportunities just to
have fun i i
uh so i'm
you know some some of my most
important contributions have come just
from playing around
certainly anyone's and fractional
statistics at early on was just playing
around seeing if i could break up
angular momentum into smaller units and
what that would mean
and
it's turned out to be
fascinating to to and
even
perhaps fundamentally important putting
guiding
guiding us to new kinds of laws
and even and maybe even technologically
important so it's very hard to see where
things are going to lead
and
i just so i just like to have fun and uh
well i mean i don't but okay well but
what is fun i mean partly what's fun is
discovering something that's
important and uh
and opens more doors and that people
other people are interested in so all
that factors into it but i'm not
obsessed with
uh how should i say
i'm not obsessed with banging my head
against a wall
that uh
just because just because there might be
something on the other side
and uh
you know sometimes you want to work walk
around the wall and sometime and uh
and also as i said it's it i i don't
think that
fundamental is the ultimate
or only i shouldn't say it's
ultimate or only criterion of what
important scientific work is right but
does it does does it bother you at all
that the foundations as we currently
have them where we have the standard
model which we'll talk about in a moment
in your important contributions and the
general theory of relativity that these
two
foundational structures don't cohere in
the way that we need them to does that
does that bother you well
they're pretty good i mean
astrophysicists uh
astrophysicists work in domains where
gravity is very important and so is
quantum mechanics every day and it's
very routine and we
the the problems uh at a practical level
and where practical you know is very
loosely defined
arise in just
in the natural world in in
things like
the deep interior of black holes or the
very very very early universe
that are
of course important and fascinating
but
rather
remote from most uh
experimental or observational
handles and so
not how should i say not
urgent concerns that are forced on us by
understanding the world in a concrete
way and
i mean and it's worse than that i mean
you i mean
there have been very very few
if any
uh convincing proposals for how to test
ideas about how to get beyond get
get uh consequences from how should i
say scratching the itch of uh of these
conceptual kinds of
uh
between
space-time concepts and general
relativity and quantum mechanics
i also think that those it's easy to
overstate how as i as i alluded to
how serious those tensions are i mean
as i said astrophysicists
work perfectly comfortably in domains
and and get correct descriptions that
are experimentally verified of new
phenomena where both quantum mechanics
and gravity are important
uh every day i mean but black holes are
real and we think that they
have that goals are real and
uh so far the theoretical description of
them
uh although you know it's
uh the comparisons are relatively cr are
still fairly crude
the theoretical
uh description matches existing
observations uh pretty well and then
right that
uh and and i don't know of any really
plausible concrete proposals for how
it's gonna break down
that uh so
uh so yeah so so
these questions are are uh
uh fascinating but but to me there are
other questions that are also
fascinating where
the kind of dialogue with nature might
be more
more two-sided let's turn to one of
those in fact the one for which you were
awarded the nobel prize
i just want to give people a sense of
what it is that you discovered why don't
we frame it in the in the language of
forces
and you know we've long known about the
gravitational force electromagnetic
force and i think as many people
watching this will know those forces
drop off with distance when things are
farther apart the force between them
whether it's gravitational
electromagnetic it gets smaller and it
drops off in a way that we understand
it's an inverse square law that has a
nice description in terms of lines of
force spreading out in a
three-dimensional space when it came to
the strong nuclear force when when you
began to work on this there were hints
that it was different from that so if
you give us a sense of what that is and
what the challenge was to try to
describe that mathematically
yeah well there there were experimental
uh hints although they're much clearer
in retrospect than they were at the time
but with some sophisticated uh visual
processing if you like of uh image
processing you could interpret data
that uh that was gathered as saying that
the force the straw the force between
quarks got
weak
as the quarks were very close together
or
uh in quantum mechanics
a dual statement which is
equivalent is that when their energies
relative energies got very high so the
force gets weak
which is very
counterintuitive as you said and
different from other forces
and it turns out that that behavior
is quite difficult to reconcile in
detail with the principles of quantum
mechanics
and special relativity
or as embodied in quantum field theory
and uh so
uh
when we
looked for
theoretical
embodiments of that general
phenomena that you would have a force
that gets really weak
as
uh the particles that are involved in
the force get close together uh we were
led to an almost unique
theory
of
how you could do that
and uh
it was a it's a fantastically
wonderful theory it's very has enormous
amounts of symmetry
and
we were able to draw
consequences from it besides the
motivating
idea
motivating experiments we could draw
many more detailed consequences of it
and uh and that
showed that uh
the the uh this these hints were not
misleading that that
the idea that you
we got led to a unique theory
uh turned out to be the correct theory
and uh that that that's that's how we
got the nobel prize and
and and so you're collaborating on that
who i gathered was your supervisor at
princeton at the time you're a graduate
student when this work was undertaken
david gross i gather
from what i've read
he
did not think that quantum field theory
would be able to describe this kind of
behavior and i and i and i gathered the
work that you were doing was trying to
just rule out
that this could be accommodated within
quantum field theory well he was trying
to rule it out i i was
i was more open-minded uh i i guess i
knew less or some but i was less
uh
i uh
so i i was
uh i actually
you know certain certainly hoped that
that we could reconcile uh the basic
principles with experiment but
uh in any case i just wanted to know
what the answer is is does does it is it
possible or isn't it possible the fact
that it's possible basically in just one
way was like fantastic like a gift from
heaven couldn't have been better you
know right because it it sort of was it
was like uh
uh archimedes saying you need a lever
and then i can lift the world this we
were right
with the right fulcrum we could lift the
whole and that that's
so by doing by
focusing on this very
this very uh simple property
you that the whole thing opened up it
cracked the problem that people had been
trying to crack
very unsuccessfully for decades
and
i think it was a big big surprise to the
theoretical community that
you could have
an actual quantitative precise theory of
the strong interaction
that doesn't always happen i mean you
know for for decades
people working on the nuclear
forces had kind of semi-empirical
theories and
not theories that you couldn't
systematically improve
uh
quantum field theory had a bad
reputation because of all these failures
and so
yeah so it all that changed overnight
and we were very lucky that we made this
ex
profoundly leveraged discovery
now i've seen a number
of ways of trying to give a hand-wavy
intuitive explanation for how it is that
that this force grows with distance uh
you can think of rubber bands but
they're not really that fundamental
um do you have a way of describing it
yes i think so basically it's that
gluons
the the force carriers in the strong
interaction
uh
attract each other so they tend to glom
together unlike photons which don't care
so if you think about the flux
emerging from an electric charge
it goes off in all directions and kind
of dilutes with distance
but if you think about the flux of
electric field
uh coming off a color charge in the
strong interaction where the glute the
gluons attract each other
so the flux comes off in a
uh in a coherent
one-dimensional
object like a tube
a tube or a string
and and therefore its
influence does not weaken with distance
that's how you can get a force that that
doesn't doesn't fall off with distance
until the tubes break so there's a
little more it gets more complicated but
for a while at least the force doesn't
fall off with distance and quarks can't
escape
the only the only the only way these
flux tubes
you can't make them infinitely long but
they can break into smaller flux tubes
in fact you can use that to explain why
we can't isolate individual quarks
yeah exactly
right so at that at the level of hand
waving this phenomenon that was thought
to be extremely mysterious and
and uh
prevented murray gel man who you know
invented quarks really from believing in
them
the fact that they were supposed to
never occur as as
free particles but only within
other particles
can be understood i mean
it's it's
at a hand waving level
to really
demonstrate it mathematically is still
it's actually in a good example of what
we were talking about before
there's no human proof there's no
analytic proof
and in fact the the clay foundation has
a million dollar prize for someone to
provide such a proof
but there's a proof by computer people
have
you know calculated using qcd and not
only does it confine quarks but the part
that so it doesn't produce quarks as as
as physical particles but it does
produce exactly the particles that we
see with the right masses and so so
there's no doubt that uh
that the theory uh has the confinement
property and
and
produces the physical hadrons but not
quarks uh you make reference to quantum
chromodynamics qcd this theory the
strong interactions but can you give us
that that quick hand waving explanation
using flux tubes of why you can't ever
isolate quarks
okay so a quark has
color
charge
and therefore
according to the laws of charge and
elect color electric fields come off
uh they attract each other so they go
into a tube
they can they can end on an anti-quark
say
that's there are other possibilities but
they're not qualitatively different so
it can end in an antiquark
and so so you can have a quark and an
antiquark
and then a a tube connecting them
and
if you
take the quark and the antiquark further
away from each other
uh the tube gets longer and longer
but the tube has a finite energy per
unit length
and so
if you try to take them infinitely far
apart that takes an infinite amount of
energy which is not really available so
so in any
practical experiment they only can go
off a certain distance and then
that's they can't escape and exist
as as
freely liberated particles
and so inside the proton
these quarks say are
bound together by this strong nuclear
force by the gluons the particle that
transmits the
color force of quantum chromodynamics a
question that many people ask and i
think it'd be great for you just to uh
to answer it for them is they say look
if you look at the mass of the proton
you have a certain value look at the
mass of the quarks that are meant to
make up a proton you add up the masses
of the quarks it doesn't come anywhere
near the mass of the proton what's going
on how do you explain that
well it's basically
uh
e equals m c squared
the uh
writ large i mean they uh
in fact in fact and and rearranged a
little bit we should we should we should
use the form m equals e divided by c
squared
so in a proton
uh
although the quarks are massless they're
moving around there are also lots of
gluons
i think the quarks are not quite
massless but almost massless and then so
their mass is much much smaller than the
proton you also have gluons which are
truly massless that are moving around
but because they're moving around they
have kinetic energy
energy of motion so there's a lot of
energy inside a finite region
and if you just look at it as a a a
coherent object at rest namely a proton
the mass of that object
is the energy of that object divided by
c squared
so that's how you can get the mass
without mass
i love this is a wheelerism that
actually you can do justice to mass
without mass if you start with a theory
that has no mass at all
okay if you want to be completely
realistic you put in small quark masses
but qualitatively
most of the mass by far
comes from pure energy so
so it's a really beaut in my opinion
extraordinarily beautiful
development that we can understand the
origin of mass
in terms of
a deeper level of concepts of
and as you made as you made reference to
now using powerful computers even though
analytically it's very difficult to
harness the equations of quantum
chromodynamics in fact i'm going to show
the equations in just a moment
computationally you can use these ideas
to quantitatively understand the masses
of these of these conglomerates of
particles
yes and people are doing better and
better about uh
at a better and better job of getting
the masses accurately of computing
the masses of more complicated objects
like atomic nuclei as opposed to just
protons and neutrons
uh and mesons the the uh
and but i should say that so so there
are two
domains in which we can solve the
equations effectively one of them is
uh
very static situations to get masses the
other sort of strangely enough is very
dynamic situations where the energies
are very very high
and then the asymptotic freedom comes to
our rescue
and the fact that the forces get weak at
short distances or high energies
allow us to
uh take them into account sort of
incrementally
perturbation theory and again then you
can calculate effectively
that's
most of what goes on at accelerators
these days is calculating is calculated
uh using that technique yeah and so just
turning to the equations for a moment
obviously the level of our conversation
is not such that we can delve into the
mathematics of things but
using symmetry
the powerful organizing mathematical
principle that you made reference to
earlier we can write down the equations
of quantum thermodynamics or even the
entire standard model of particle physic
which includes not just the strong but
also the weak nuclear force
electromagnetism we can write it down in
a really compact form people have
printed up t-shirts with it so really
you know it's really something just a
few symbols in its most symmetric
representation the fact that there are
on the order of a couple dozen
parameters within the standard model of
particle physics that give us the the
particle masses and charges and things
of that sort
do you consider those parameters a
target for future research to understand
from first principles or do you think
look some things you just take from
experiments you put them in your
equations and you go forward
well i'd like to think that that
the
pure numbers that that that appear in
the standard model that there there are
a couple of dozen of them
uh that those things should be
uh
aspirational targets to get uh
more profound
that that you know that's
the money version of getting a deeper
understanding is calculating more stuff
from few from more basic principles
uh
however
i don't see that i don't see the ideas
that will get us there
uh
unfortunately
uh
you know they're they're as you know
string theory in particular claims to be
a theory of everything
but uh doesn't really not have
uh con
constructive algorithms and machinery
that enables would enable you to do
these calculations
uh the
there are so what and
yeah so
it's it's been a very frustrating i
think not only to me and to many people
to uh who who would have liked to
compute those numbers i mean in the
early days in the 70s when when gage
theories were new
uh there was a there
we
we tried to build models where we could
correlate some of these numbers and so
forth but
uh
it mostly came up empty
i would say that there are two
glorious
exceptions to that
that i think are very
important and point the way i hope to
the future
one is that uh
within the standard model
the relative strength
of the different forces
strong weak electromagnetic and
gravitational for that matter
are all independent and sort of the
ratios between them are pure numbers
that that we should aspire to calculate
and by introducing
ideas that maybe the forces unify at
large distances
i'm sorry small distances or very high
energies this is sort of just taking the
asymptotic freedom calculations and
running with them
to much higher scales to see if they all
come together and they do and so so that
that uh
well they do at least roughly and that
that that uh
uh so that that indicates that we uh
might be
and it's not crazy to think we have all
the ingredients we need to get a unified
theory and but we would like to have
more supporting evidence that the
assumptions that go into this
calculation are correct
but that's that's one and the other of
course is axions so that that we have a
parameter
that sort of by rights
should be of order unity
but numerically is
i mean by by
experimental constraints numerically is
constrained to be more like apart in 10
billion
so really really really tiny uh
one would like to have a qualitative
explanation of that
and we do we have a quality we have a
candidate qualitative explanation
that
has uh
a certain elegance to it
and also uh
suggests further experiments it turns
out that it leads you to
predict the existence of a new kind of
particle so-called axion that
might very well provide the dark matter
of the universe and we're getting
building up the necessary theoretical
and experimental muscles to to have
realistic chances of detecting it so
with that actually i i would like to
turn
to uh questions of of dark matter i mean
with the
tremendous success of the standard model
of particle physics incorporating
quantum chromodynamics we've
understood so much of the data that
comes out of accelerators and actually
toward the end i want to hear your
thoughts on maybe some of the cracks or
the opportunities and some very recent
data but dark matter is a real big
issue a big problem that's been around
since the 30s uh from a variety of
perspectives we've come to the
recognition that there's got to be more
stuff out there in the heavens then
gives off light dark stuff studies of
emotions of spinning galaxies and
clusters of galaxies and so forth and
that brings up an issue which relates to
your comments about unification because
you said that these four strains almost
come together and there is a higher
symmetry that people investigate and
have invested called super symmetry and
when you include in the right manner
supersymmetric particles in these
calculations
the four strains appeared to come
together
even better than in the in in the
standard model and moreover there was a
dark matter candidate that naturally
emerged or even a collection of dark
matter
so what's your current view of super
symmetry as an approach to unification
and to dark matter yeah i was certainly
a fan of that approach to unification i
mean i basically invented it then uh
but the uh and the dark matter
is is a very serious competitor to
axions is is having
uh super symmetry
uh
fairly mildly broken so you would see a
low energy
remnants of it and one of the particles
that
arises there or typically i should not
in all models but in in many models you
find a particle that has suitable
properties
to provide the dark matter
and
of course people have been aware of this
possibility for quite a while now and
it was one of the motivations for
experiments at the lhc
it's been the motivation for many many
uh astrophysical searches uh big
detectors that that were designed to uh
detect this kind of dark matter if if
it's out there
so far that's all come up
empty uh
was that surprising to was that
surprising to you or disappointing or
hey it's just how it is
it was well it i mean i take it as it
comes i i don't have any alternative but
but uh the uh
i'd say yes it was a little bit
surprising
uh but not disappointing because i i'm
i'd rather have axions i think they're
very they're prettier and more logical
kind of
uh and more interesting in many ways the
story's not over yet so people are still
looking and
there's the hope hope hope
springs eternal
uh
so we'll just have to see but uh but you
know
logically you could you could certainly
have
i would be very disappointed
if the unification calculations
uh were just a sort of cruel joke on the
part of god that
that
that they seem to point to supersymmetry
at low energies but actually ha ha
just a coincidence uh but you know the
proof of the proof is in the pudding you
have to find the particles and so forth
there's no sign of them despite a lot a
lot of hard work to try to find them
uh however that that's distinct and
always has been distinct in my mind
from
uh
the
uh supersymmetric uh particle providing
the dark matter
there are many
ways of having supersymmetric models in
which
you get you don't provide the dark
matter there's too little
or just there's no stable particle uh
there are different versions and and so
uh that's
that's certainly to my mind that would
be the best
best of all possible worlds and we'll
we'll see how it goes i mean we already
have that i mean we have significant
contributions to the density of the
universe from neutrinos for instance
they're they're like i think like one
percent of the density
so it's not it's not
minuscule uh but but it but it is and
they are they are a kind of dark matter
so
you could have different contributions
but i'd certainly like axions to to
dominate and they're i think they're
pretty good theoretical reasons to think
that they should yeah your uh your your
poetic reference to god and playing a
joke brings to the mine einstein's
remark that you know suttle is the lord
but i think he finished it by saying
malicious he is not you know and it
would feel it would feel a little bit
malicious to have these forces almost
meet and and not quite but let's then
turn to axions i mean that's a
it's a rich and
somewhat complex story and if you could
just perhaps
help us understand it it begins
not by thinking about dark matter at all
it begins by thinking about some
fundamental symmetries again
of the of the equations maybe you can
take us through a little bit of cp and t
and how accidents come into that story
ever since
modern
physical science started really with
with uh with
people like galileo and especially
newton where you had
equations to look at that you took very
seriously so the the laws have had
a
property
that
is not only not necessary for
understanding the world but it's kind of
an embarrassment
that is that if you imagine running time
backwards
you get the same laws
so
whereas everyday life doesn't look at
all the same forwards and backwards in
time uh the fundamental laws like the
newton's laws of motion and laws of
gravity
and then
continuing for many many decades for
centuries with
maxwell's equations and
all and the quantum mechanics and all
the revolutions and physics that
happened
the the basic laws retained that
property
which is really
why this really weird
property is
in fact people
had to have to
exercise their wits
to
convince themselves that having this
property and the fundamental laws could
be reconciled with observations at all
because you have to somehow explain
irreversibility and so okay in everyday
life yeah
but it could have been that it was just
you know it's just that's just the way
it is
it's at rock bottom it's kind of an
elegant thing to say that that the laws
have this property but
uh but then in 1964
uh
some very
you know to an outsider extremely
obscure experiments
having to do with the decay of unstable
particles at accelerators k mesons
uh
indicated that the the laws don't have
this property not exactly just very
nearly not exactly right right the work
of cronin and fitch on the decay of
chaons revealing after the right
analysis a slight asymmetry between
processes and folding in one temporal
order versus the reverse yeah so that
really that really even sharpened the
question well you know it's not no
longer could you say well that's rock
bottom that's just the way it is you
have to explain why it's almost true but
not quite
and uh anyway to skipping to the chase
people developed
uh
as the stan
once we had the standard model we had
the understanding that uh we had very
powerful principles that
organized most of what we need to know
about the world
uh certainly for purposes of engineering
and and for
things that happen at accelerators were
based on very very constraining
principles
quantum mechanics
special relativity
and um
and
this
high degree of symmetry this whole
called gauge symmetry which
and if you combined those things
you could make a theory you could you
could see that that given the particles
we have
and given these general constraints
uh we almost could understand this
strange behavior of the fundamental laws
that they are almost but not quite the
same if you run times backwards
on on the basis that
other more profound principles constrain
the possibilities so much
that there's just a tiny
window of opportunity
for this uh time reversal symmetry to be
violated
and uh
actually there there are two
possible interactions it turns out when
you analyze
the constraints two possible
interactions
that are consistent with all the general
principles and yet give some violation
of the symmetry between time forward and
time back
and one of them has led to an extremely
fruitful theory
uh one of these interactions does occur
in nature explains the cronin and fitch
observations these camas on things and a
lot more a lot more subsequent
experiments and there's a nice
quantitative theory with
hundreds of experimental verifications
very quantitative of of that particular
interaction then there's another
interaction that's also allowed by
general principles but doesn't happen
phenomenologically the experiments just
don't reveal the existence of this
possible
interaction so so that that and that's
this part in 10 to the 10th
coincidence that i mentioned
so then uh
that that's a great opportunity there's
something obviously very profound
missing
in our understanding of nature
that
seems to then you can really put your
finger on it there's this tiny number
how do you explain this tiny number
and it turns out that a fairly modest
expansion of the standard model so not
really changing the principles but just
expanding the model to include a little
bit more stuff
can give you
an explanation
a very very compelling explanation of of
why this number is so small
but the price of it is you get a new
particle
this is the axion that's part of the
expanded expansion of the model you get
this new particle the axion
and you named it right this is a i named
it yeah based on a detergent or
something that you yeah after a laundry
detergent that that because
well i like the name
when i first saw it even before i before
i decided i was going to go into physics
actually i was okay
so it was a particle name awaiting a
particle
that's right exactly but then then the
stars were really aligned because it
turns out this particle cleans up a
problem with an axial current
so
clearly it was the right thing
and uh
anyway so so there is this this particle
with very unusual but very specific
properties
there's basically
a one parameter theory that governs
the
complete
behavior of this particle including its
mass all its interactions
we don't know what the value of that
parameter is but so that
makes it difficult to search but but
okay but but it could be worse this is
sort of like what the higgs particle was
before it was discovered
uh the uh
the
uh
then it turned out that uh
and this was not
part of the initial
mandate so to speak for the
or the initial uh idea behind this
proposal the the
it turns out that if you put this theory
into
uh the big bang into cosmology you can
calculate how much axions get produced
and uh
what whether they
survive to the present-day universe and
and you find remarkably yes they get
produced
quite abundantly they survive into the
present-day universe and in fact they
have all the right properties to provide
the dark matter
right in detail they produce cold
they interact very very weakly with
ordinary matter so they i mean it's
uh how should i say it's not a very high
bar in the sense but but very few
particles actually clear it that uh that
these make a plausible candidate uh for
the dark matter and and it didn't have
to be that way and to me that's
another indication
beyond uh beyond the laundry detergent
cleaning up
a problem with an axial current another
indication that this is on the right
track that that and or malicious deity
with an interesting mathematical sense
of humor right yeah even more delicious
malicious deed right laughing at us uh
the uh
um
yeah but but
but but the the exciting thing about
having a a theory that that's
uh well motivated and and concrete
is that now
uh you know what you
you're faced with a
very specific challenge okay
you want to design antennas to sign
detectors
that would turn this pervasive
fluid of dark matter particles
into
signals that we can actually detect very
much like the challenge that astronomers
faced in finding the three degree
microwave background radiation
you just have to have appropriate
receivers
this is even more difficult it turns out
because the coupling of the axions is
very very weak
but uh
there's hope and so you've actually
played a hand in helping the
experimenters design these antennas too
you're not just hands off on trying to
find yeah no well well
a couple of years ago
uh together with
two postdocs we uh
we had what i think is a in all modesty
a brilliant proposal for a new kind of
antenna
that
has a good chance i think of of that you
know has
on paper and by now it's not just on
paper now there are prototypes and
and we're putting together very high
powered experimental collaboration
called the alpha collaboration
to uh
that that will
well
i mean will i mean
i'll be very embarrassed if it doesn't
at this point
test this hypothesis within a very very
interesting range of parameters
uh definitively for the first time yeah
and so
just going a little bit further let's
say this all
works out and we we understand
the dark matter i mean another mystery
that we don't really have time to
discuss is the the nature of dark energy
which is another
dark ingredient to the makeup of the
energy budget of the cosmos
i i do wonder the following we are still
within the the mathematical framework of
a framework that aligns even with
newton's view of the world we have these
equations they're more sophisticated
than newtons they're more wide-ranging
but we still have equations that we
supplement with initial conditions and
that's sort of the framework do you
imagine that we will be able to go
beyond that architecture at some point
where the laws and the initial data are
blended together into one structure as
opposed to this too structured approach
i'd like to think so yeah i think i
think that that's certainly a noble
aspiration
yeah so so yes i do think that that it
really should be that way
i mean if you the the the perspective
already of special relativity
brings together space and time
into a unity and so
the the procedure of having equations
which slice
take time slices and evolve you from one
to the next
is within that context
somewhat artificial looking so one yeah
i definitely think
there's something missing there
have you thought i mean have you worked
in that direction do you have any ideas
well i've i've thought but i haven't
worked because i
didn't get it i didn't think of anything
that i could really get a grip on right
and
yeah just so we can turn to a final
section here
there's some physicists and some
scientists more generally
who are really driven by just you know
getting the answer to this or that
quality of the world measure that mass
measure that coupling and so forth
you certainly
give a sense of someone who does science
for
a much larger reason i mean you get a
sense from your books and your articles
that that the beauty and the mystery and
the wonder is really that captures you
much more than this or that detail i
mean so do you first of all is it
accurate and do you find that science
helps illuminate some of the the bigger
questions that that transcend the
details of science itself
oh yes
uh
well my my latest book is about that i
mean the fundamentals very much is is
moving in that direction
trying to figure out what it all means
uh the the
uh
so and and you know and i could talk
about particular things i think the the
a couple of things that really do shine
through from the understanding of
the fundamentals of the physical world
is first of all that it's remarkably
comprehensible that
we really can
get a description that's precise and
rich and true
uh for a tremendous body of of uh
phenomena and it
you know and the proof is in the pudding
and so does me you know i'm talking to
you using
using the the fruits of understanding of
quantum mechanics and and uh
and band theory
and
the ability to manipulate uh
electrons and make them make them do
clever things and photons and so on
and but i also think that there are kind
of uh philosophical almost theological
consequences that you can draw
answers to questions or
maybe not answers may be the wrong
word but illumination of questions
that traditionally have been thought of
as philosophical or even theological
i think come from
a deep understanding of the world
so
for instance i think the concept of
complementarity
that
to understand some object or or domain
uh properly may require different
perspectives that are almost or
actually mutually incomprehensible
uh i think is is to me illuminates it's
a kind of wisdom that illuminates many
questions
and also uh
encourages tolerance and mind expansion
uh maybe i'll just mention one a third
aspect so so there's the the way the
world actually works is very beautiful
and comprehensible
the the uh
this principle of complementarity that
to understand things properly you may
have to take different points of view
and in quantum mechanics you definitely
need to but in other domains it's still
i think very helpful
and uh
and the third i think is the scientific
community as kind of a model of
a successful human endeavor
where
what do we mean by successful well you
could mean different things but but
but
giving us control over the world
giving people a lot of pleasure
and
the things that go into that success we
can see are
openness communication
willingness to admit error
pushing things hard i think
competition but within a you know not
within within a very structured
rule-based
environment uh all those things i think
are are lessons
that
we should take from the scientific
community
and bring out
and
expand it to more into uh
larger levels of human activity i mean
so some people look at the work that
theoretical physicists do
as esoteric as somehow you know outside
the realm of what matters to human
beings and so just jumping off from what
you just mentioned one final question i
mean do you think if by some miracle the
fraction
of the population that
understood science at the level
of understanding how it works and the
insight it provides and the illumination
that it gives us do you think that if
the fraction of people who just had that
sense of what science is about grew
larger would it change
the way we act toward each other as
members of the same species can you
imagine it having an impact on on the
way the world at large governs itself
it's beautiful to think so
and i do i don't think it's crazy no i i
i do i do believe that yes and
that that
that
is a big motivation to me actually not
not only in my work but also in trying
to reach out to the public and
and
expand human consciousness in general
i mean you don't have to be a scientist
to
understand some of these fundamental
lessons
and they are mind expanding
they're helpful
in
putting things in perspective
and
i highly recommend it
well with that thank you so much frank
for joining us and again congratulations
on being a recipient of the john
templeton prize and of course for all
the wonderful contributions you've made
to science and
as you just mentioned to the public's
understanding of science more generally
thank you so much
thank you
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
so
you